we previewed earlier this week that this
might happen and it sort of has Donald
Trump's former national one of his
former national security advisors John
Bolton
one of the most disgusting neocon war
hawks of the last 20 years has been
called to testify in the impeachment
inquiry of Donald Trump next week if
Bolton shows up and we'll talk about
that Bolton would be really the first
major witness in this entire thing and
Bolton as I've said before is not a good
guy he was one of the architects of the
Iraq war
he just loves a good old war for either
regime change and/or oil
he's a total hothead but he believes in
defending his values as he sees them now
they're not my values they're probably
not yours but Bolton believes that
Trump's values are not the right ones he
was not pleased with Rudy Giuliani smear
seeking projects under Trump he called
them Rudy's drug deals including looking
for dirt on political opponents
including Joe Biden if Bolton testifies
it could be absolutely explosive we have
every reason to think that Bolton could
do serious damage to Donald Trump based
on what he knows the White House on the
one hand of course is urging Bolton and
others just don't show up no surprise
that's been their approach all along now
let me immediately give you what some
are saying is bad news but I don't
actually think it is last night John
Bolton's attorney and of course if you
worked for Trump you probably need a
lawyer right about now and Bolton has
won Bolton's lawyer says that without a
subpoena John Bolton's not going to be
there and we might imagine that this is
a suggestion that Bolton is not going to
show up I don't believe that that's the
case it is not uncommon in these
situations that the potential witness
will request a subpoena or say I won't
show up without one because if they show
up voluntarily and say things that Trump
or whoever take issue with that is a
very different scenario legally for
Bolton than if he was subpoenaed to
testify so it is not uncommon that for
their own protection from future
potential reduction of liability from
something like a civil suit or perjury
you know whatever it is that from
might allege john bolton engages in it
is not uncommon for bolton to say for
someone in Bolton's position rather to
say i will only show up if I am
subpoenaed here's the bottom line if we
can get Bolton to this committee Bolton
is a bloodthirsty and ruthless neocon
whose political views I find absolutely
disgusting but that doesn't matter I
would not want Bolton as my public
political enemy and that indeed may be
terrible for Donald Trump this could get
ugly in the best way very very quickly
we live in extraordinarily strange times
I acknowledge that where someone as
depraved in his political beliefs as
John Bolton might actually signal or be
the catalyst for the start of what is
ultimately maybe an attempt to write our
democracy which has been turned on its
head by this administration that phrase
about politics makes strange bedfellows
has become almost apocryphal at this
point but it seems particularly accurate
right now and if Bolton's going to be
the catalyst for maybe starting to write
the ship that is on its way down then
that's a good thing and we should
anxiously and positively await the
testimony of John Bolton I'll let you
know as soon as I know whether he has
been subpoenaed and whether he will
indeed be there next week let's take a
quick break give us a like on Facebook
at facebook.com slash David Pakman show
after this there is a tweet for
everything that is the meme that best
applies to what we will discuss after
this quick break